[Music]
I'm Alfred Spector I'm the CTO at 2
Sigma and I'll be introducing of the
talk and making some comments at the end
I have with me doing most of the
presentation on the talk
two of our engineers one in our overall
cloud engineering team in one that is
focused on security engineering in the
cloud focused on security engineering is
NIC Arvin itis harvan et's he is been
with us and just done a tremendous job
facilitating the connection between
systems and security something that's
critical for all of us as we move into
the cloud and we are grateful he joined
us Jacques
Klaus has been with 2 Sigma on about
what two years two and a half years
two and a half years with background in
cloud and systems and other companies
and has also been someone who's
implemented much of our security
controls and other strategies in our
cloud computing so they really know what
needs to happen and they've had
experience not just not just with Google
but very broadly with cloud computing
before I start I have one very important
message I understand your seats fully
recline so I have never given the talk
before where seats fully reclined so we
will measure ourselves if every one seat
is reclined at the end of the talk we
will not be invited back to Google next
I understand so try to stay at least
moderately vertical here in this
presentation all right let me just talk
a little bit about two sigma in this No
so two sigma is a financial firm and a
tech firm both broadly our mission is to
get huge amounts of useful indicative
privacy-preserving
financial data to draw inferences from
that and to optimize economic outcomes
we're certainly known as a hedge fund
but we do a lot more than that for
example we are using data now in a very
rapidly growing insurance operation
where we're looking to greatly almost
revolutionize the way that small
business insurance is done to assist in
capital formation and reduce overheads
etc any case we have very broad and
interesting challenges in our space we
collect almost a petabyte of data a
month so it's a fairly large operation
and to do this we feel that we need to
be a tech company as well as a finance
company and that's a complicated balance
to achieve we can't be at the back end
of technology as some finance companies
have traditionally been otherwise you
won't have the talent to be at the
leading edge of our industry but if we
adopt every new tech thing without
concerns we have 55 billion dollars in
assets under management lots of
regulatory structures and the like so we
have to actually be quite quite careful
as well we're about 1,500 people roughly
speaking half engineering in the firm so
it is really a fascinating question in
the security realm I think the hardest
realm of all in the space of IT or
computer science is how to create an
environment that's incredibly flexible
and that has appropriate levels of
security one of the things we're most
concerned about not the only thing but
one of them is the concern about how do
we grow as a firm without the risk of
data loss growing proportionally with a
number of employees that we have and we
want to do that while still having a lot
of interaction among our employees
internally so without having to wall
them off from each other and prevent
sharing without having to wall them off
from new technology or the internet to
allow for this fluid environment where
we can actually have sort of our cake
and eat a - and that's that's the really
interesting problem I'm suspect that's a
problem
for many of you in this room and we're
going to be talking about part of that
in this presentation today as we talk
about how to do cloud computing in a way
that doesn't have a significant risk of
exfiltration one more comment to make
we're really interested in how do we
make our whole ecosystem more secure and
vibrant that's why we're giving the talk
that's beneficial to us I think it's
beneficial to others in our industry and
broadly to cloud computing and to Google
as well so we're doing that in the hope
that we can share best practices we're
giving I think for more talks on
security over the next two days you can
find them in fact we'll put up a slide
at the end on other talks that we are
there giving or participating in we're
also giving a talk on serverless
distributed computing in the cloud
tomorrow and also Jacques is involved in
giving a talk on halite which is a
fascinating AI programming competition
we think it'll be the largest term AI
programming competition yet run in the
third incarnation this year and it
explores very interesting problems not
just about how to get artificial
intelligence bots to do as well as
people but to actually do things that
people could never do before so
self-driving cars they're interesting
but we people do self we do cars pretty
well where you have to look at problems
that are harder than what people can do
certainly in the investment management
realm and halite begins to get at what
can we start doing with computers that
we can't even conceive of doing as
humans all right without further ado let
me turn this over now to Nick who will
begin the more specific parts of the
presentation Thank You Alfred very
briefly I Alfred touched a little on
some of our challenges and our threat
models I'm just briefly gonna recap some
of the key points there those things
really drive the way we think about
security and security controls I'm gonna
hand over to Jack to talk about our
evolution and our journey along the path
and heading into Google Cloud and then
I'm going to spend quite a bit of
I'm talking about how we work tightly
with Google to build native security
controls and implement those controls
and then finally wrap up with a few
lessons learned so a point that that
Alfred underscored and I just want to
quickly reiterate is that our attack
surface is very different to what you'd
imagine for most organizations using
cloud computing resources if we don't
have anything consumer-facing we don't
have to be up and exposed all the time
and worry about DDoS and things like
that really what we're focused on is
internal use cases use of managed
services processing data so we have a
very sort of inside-out attack surface
compared to most organizations
Alfred mentioned how key intellectual
property is for us and really when we
think about threat models and risk
mitigation this is the factor that
drives a lot of what we put into as
considerations and when we design
controls we want to protect our IP again
that's that's difficult to do without
hampering people's workflows we don't
want to take away access to data or
systems or segment people from each
other so that they can't collaborate so
mitigating insider risk is really
difficult and one of the things that's
worth highlighting is you know people
talk about insider risk and the
immediate stretches we don't trust our
people and that's not the case right we
we definitely want a model where one
single person is not in a position to
completely be able to exfiltrate data or
code but that also happens accidentally
and if you followed the thread of how
sophisticated attackers target
organizations really what they're doing
is they're targeting individuals with
legitimate access and then using that
compromised individuals access to move
laterally access their data and
ultimately exfiltrate that data so when
we think about inside a risk we think
about all of those cases we're not just
thinking about malicious insiders and
that's an important point
finally we're not beholden to many of
the regulatory considerations that a lot
of organizations working in the cloud
all like we don't process payment card
data we don't necessarily have PII or
HIPPA considerations but we are very
strongly you know consistent about what
our compliance team is is is interested
in
and mandating that certain aspects of
our business don't necessarily have
access to data that other businesses are
working on and and this can even go a
little further in our research teams
were very cognizant of research or IP
and in some cases you may have
researchers in the same team working on
the same data set but not able to view
the output of each other's model code
that's really important to us so we
think about that as well when we're
designing controls so Jack will will
talk a little about our journey into the
cloud and some of the challenges we
faced so like like many of you we had a
dream and our dream was to connect
directly with the cloud to have a truly
elastic internal infrastructure that
extended to an external infrastructure
and for that we like many of you look to
Google of course unfortunately when we
started Google was in its humble
beginnings and I am wasn't exactly
everything that we wanted it to be it
was very primitive and so much so that
they only gave us three primitive I am
options owner at her and viewer and
unfortunately that this allowed us to go
more broadly in toward the scope that
one and we wanted things that were more
granular there are things in each of
these that we desired and things of them
that we didn't and we wanted
combinations of them so at that point
because of that desire we were unable to
jump into that space and we decided to
wait a little bit until it was a little
bit more mature and when it started
getting more mature we finally reached
the point that we felt was enough for us
to actually jump directly into Google
and be kind of happy with what we had
with some changes that we'd have to do
and Google as it stood at that point
actually had very very good services and
it did everything very very well but it
was again in its beginnings and Google
does this Irit of model really well in
that you can think of it in terms of a
car if you're building a car you build
really good wheels and then you build a
really good steering wheel and then you
build the seats and then you build the
chassis you don't just make a bad car
you make very very good little parts and
you put them together and we wanted in
at the beginning of that so we had to
deal with sometimes with driving a car
with just wheels so when when we try to
make our
first Connection we saw all these
amazing services that unfortunately
we're all directly connected to the
internet and we could use them and then
we'd have an open gateway which is not
what we desired if we're trying to block
exfiltration risks so we either opened
up or we didn't use anything and we just
had VMs everywhere which we could really
do without Google and that's not what we
wanted on top of that we didn't really
have a direct connect connection to
Google at that time directly
interconnect didn't really exist we were
in the type of connection that just went
into the Google fabric but not entered
what we wanted it or projects and that
in that that inherently meant that we
had to do something about that in which
our case was more to try to get a VPN
connection in there and that required a
lot of tuning from both sides and we
didn't really need the level of speeds
that most people need when they're doing
VPNs we needed much greater speeds most
people and they think about our talking
about megabits megabytes per second
we're talking about many gigabytes per
second connections and of course on top
of all of that Google had these nice
bonuses that were actually really cool
and really useful the first time for
example we saw cloud as a sage we were
in love with it the idea that we could
just directly connect to something and
we didn't really care that much at that
point to that specific exfiltration risk
because at that point exfiltration is at
the speed of typing and you can do that
in an email so that wasn't a problem of
course problematically we found out that
there were extra features that again a
boon to many to us weren't that useful
such as the upload file directly button
in the cloud ssh other things such as
serial port connectivity serial port is
an amazing feature if you have network
problems you connect directly to Google
you forego all of your of your firewall
rules you forego everything and you just
connect doesn't matter if you have an
external IP or not which of course we
didn't really want and it was either go
or not go for that service accounts
another amazing feature from Google also
brought about quite a number of risks
they come with refresh tokens that
didn't expire and could be reached from
anywhere without any IP restriction and
they were a short string that you could
just write in a piece of paper and take
out and on top of that the
no egress firewall you could just send
data outside as much as you wanted and
there were also a number of overloaded
calls at the time which again it's it's
great it's Google magic it means that
you know in very few steps you can do a
lot but at the same time for us it means
that we lose some of our protection for
instance one great example is we had the
I am connection directly to BQ select
which a bigquery select sorry B career
select which also allows you to export
data so you either didn't select things
in bigquery or you export a data it
wasn't it wasn't a clear selection
within them so how did how could we
target all of these things at once and
for that originally we proxied
everything so everything we had to do
had to go through these two proxies one
which we call the provisioning agent and
get an Oracle takoyaki the provisioning
agent was basically a strong
precondition checker with our ordering
logic so it was a direct rest command
that kind of map to some of the Google
ones for things that we trusted and when
you wouldn't change over time and held a
very very privileged account to do all
those things and to change projects and
it only did things the right way in the
right order such that in no step
anything could be ever compromised if
anything went wrong and if anything went
wrong it did everything backwards in the
right order and it made sure that no one
called things that they couldn't such as
creating an image with a serial port
open in it
conversely takoyaki our other tool which
is kind of just a big joke a big pun
that we made because originally it
evolved from squid and takoyaki is
really you know squid well done because
it's fried it was it checked rest calls
for a specific commands and allowed us
to really be more allow us to integrate
directly with g-cloud because we could
just allow some commands and deny other
commands and it also injected the tokens
into the call so that we couldn't we
didn't need to worry about people just
thinking them out because they didn't
have access to them and of course both
of those meant that anytime anything
changed we needed to change everything
in our end of course Google was awesome
and up streamed a lot of the things that
we needed changed but for a lot of time
that wasn't great on top of that there's
Google magic you ask for something
Google goes poof and it's solved so for
things like the serial port
we talked to them and they made changes
that allowed us to really just turn it
off or one other specific example we had
what we call the image exfiltration hack
at one specific point from one day to
the other again Google went poof and we
had this amazing feature that actually
allowed you to just move images from one
project to another which is actually
very useful but again not that much for
us because suddenly that meant that we
could have a very lockdown project with
images with very very strong IP that you
could just copy anywhere and then just
exfiltrate if that other project was
open again Google went poof again and we
had a button that allowed us to turn it
off and on top of that we had to add a
little bit of our special touch so
things like sam'l that allowed us to
connect directly to our ad FS which
meant that we could login only from our
internal internal system there so really
there it was protected from external
people our OS was custom so we removed a
lot of the Google SSH stuff that could
also provide some risks for things like
G suite we added proxy headers that only
allowed us to go to our own G suite
things and this lolled exfiltration and
we had our own proxy blackmagic for
everything else of course all of those
brought about some hardship and struggle
in the sense that the VPN as I said
before was expensive not just to buy but
also to maintain any change any increase
meant that we had some to have some very
very hard communications of Google to
change everything we were doing a lot of
duplication we're doing a lot of work
that Google would end up doing
afterwards anyway and thankfully again
the up streamed a lot of what we did so
it wasn't for nothing but you know they
they definitely do it better than us so
why why should we do it and ultimately
to ensure that everything is correct we
had to figure out all the undocumented
endpoints and all of the undocumented I
am statements which we still recommend
that you do but it's still a hardship
and now back to Nick for a brief
philosophical interlude Thank You Jay so
the challenges that we had were in part
driven as Jack mentioned by us wanting
to enable us velocity and wanting to
enable people to harness the power of
the cloud but also having very definite
security considerations in security
trolls we did go into this eyes wide
open that we were we were iterating but
as we were iterating we were racking up
a lot of tech debt and one of the things
that I believe very philosophical that
security teams should do is to the quote
that Richard Smith gave when he was the
director of security at HC security
teams really should be enable as for the
rest of engineering and for the business
right anytime security becomes a blocker
ultimately your security posture will
suffer because people will find ways to
read around you and also you'll lose
credibility because you're no longer
business enabler so the steps that we'd
taken while they were really great at
getting us into the cloud really quickly
we fully understood that we picked up
this debt and we were causing this kind
of friction for the rest of our business
teams and we really wanted a way to
resolve these issues in a very cloud
native way it seemed like we were doing
things the old-fashioned way and that
this wasn't an ideal State for us to
iterate quickly and to move faster so we
sat around and we thought about how we
could address these issues and and at
this point it was really clear to us
that as a design partner with Google a
lot of the value for us would be in
surfacing these issues to Google right
as a partner we had to surface our
concerns and we had to talk to them and
understand what was available for us to
address those concerns well what was
potentially road mapped so that we could
make the right decisions around
investing in mitigating some of our
risks in the short term or actually just
holding off but making sure that we
weren't engineering things that weren't
gonna last and we're just destroying
engineer productivity I one of the
things that was also a value added from
our perspective to Google is as we heard
this morning
to paraphrase one from Diane about
Google's mission statement Google exists
to organize the world's information and
make it easily accessible in our case we
really wanted to do the opposite we
wanted to organize as much data as we
could but not make it accessible to
anyone outside it to Sigma so this
perspective whilst are not unique to our
industry was a little early for a lot of
the Google Cloud understanding because
most of the mess up adopters are
consumer facing organizations the
services are built to enable somebody to
iterate really rapidly and put
things out there so we thought this
two-way conversation would be really
helpful in terms of as partners us
informing each other and then developing
native controls so I'm going to talk a
little more in depth about some of these
controls and some of the ones that are
relevant to us and the journey that we
had and in the specific use case I just
want to point out that obviously
security is is multiple layers in the
stack so you have to be concerned about
application security host security right
now I'm not going to talk about any of
those I'm just going to talk about the
cloud native services that we use to
protect the Google cloud
likewise Jack touched on G suite I'm not
going to talk about that either because
that could be a whole talk by itself so
the first controller was really helpful
for us was organization policies and
still is today many of the risk factors
that Jack had talked about bringing up
VM instances with external IP addresses
the serial console access things like
being able to configure which of our
projects was the source of truth for
images that could be used in other
projects because we were using our own
custom images and then conversely the
flipside of that is making sure that the
custom configurations that we were
baking into our own images we didn't
want those to just be usable anywhere so
also being able to restrict where those
were used by policy was important to us
and of course another important policy
is the the fact that we could configure
that only trusted user principles from
our domains that were that we wanted to
allow could be added to any Google
resources an organization policies
allowed us to do all of these things
very powerfully very minimal work
involved and we could configure them at
any level in the hierarchy from the
organization itself to specific folders
to actual individual project levels like
that gave us a lot of power as offered
mentioned I'm talking a little more
about organization policies and the
specifics of what we configured in a
talk on Thursday with with the GCE theme
so we can go into a lot more depth there
but these are really powerful control
and we evolved a few of these together
with Google and one of the lovely things
that happened was all of the manual
things that Google had to do for us on
the backend organization policies
eventually replaced those and they were
completely configurable and transparent
to us
VPC service controls is another huge one
this one I really can't understate the
importance of for our business in the
context of this talk data exfiltration
is again our biggest threat vector and
our biggest consideration and VPC
service controls really allowed us to
really extend the use case of the Google
cloud in a safe manner
which allowed us to then protect our
data so VPC service controls as a
concept is an interesting one if you
think about an analogy of traditional
systems and network security you can
really control your parameter in a
Google Cloud V PC you have complete
control over how you set up the routes
so as we do in many of our projects you
can just strip the internet route
entirely you can also control firewall
policies both ingress and egress now
that that's available to us what do you
do with API access but if you want to
configure and work with managed services
which really is a lot of the value of
the Google cloud things like Google
Cloud Storage bigquery being able to
work with those api's but also protect
your data and make sure that your data
is contained that's a really significant
problem and it led to us having very
complicated workflows again in the
spirit of not wanting to block
innovation from one of our teams what we
did was we ended up having an
environment that we created that was
completely standalone and not connected
back to our internal network
we had a very convoluted path with which
the researchers and the engineers and
that team were able to access that
environment and in there they had home
servers that they could then use to
access services like bigquery GCSE data
proc data flow Manassas the internet the
problem there was from a security
perspective we had to maintain two
different identities for these users
right one was their actual identity that
they could use from within to Sigma
where we had to do a ton of research and
engineering and have proxies and all
sorts of other things to ensure that
that was a read on the type role where
data can be pushed out and then we had
to maintain a separate role for them
that was tied to their home servers with
which they could use these services with
abandon and and that's not ideal right
you have researchers and engineers with
duplicated environments they're not
comfortable on their own servers they
also can do things like work
external data sets and then join those
with internal data sets within two sigma
and really unlock the value of research
in that way
so what VPC surf's controls allowed us
to do is now we can unlock those
workflows so at this point we have a
situation where we have an environment
configured where a researcher within two
sigma can work on their own research
environment on their own servers their
home service and they can natively
access services like Google Cloud
storage and bigquery and the power of
that is incredible in allowing our
researchers to really use internal
datasets external data and accelerate
research without producing massive
complicated infrastructure again there's
a lot of nuance to VPC service controls
there's a there's another talk that I'm
speaking and with that product team on
Thursday as well we will talk about more
of the mechanics of the technical depth
of it but this was a really key thing
where we worked very tightly with Google
the collaboration was huge you know was
conceived here a year ago in some
meetings Jacquet over lunch with was Sam
writing some of the product team and
we've collaborated really closely over
the last year and seen the product
evolve we used it extensively we Penn
tested it we did a lot of research on it
as early access adopters and really we
even contributed to some of the
evolution things like bridging of zones
and some of the more complicated
scenarios and representing our own
internal network as a zone for VP C
service controls so a lot of depth there
but this is one of the massive things
that unlocked a lot of velocity for our
business in a very very safe manner
Jack touched on our I was with VPN
connectivity I'm dedicated interconnect
now really gives us private dedicated
connectivity at the Google cloud the
bandwidth we have is huge and we we no
longer need to tax our internet proxies
we no longer need to maintain really
complicated policies for a lot of use
cases on those proxies because the
connectivity is private and this coupled
together with the VP C service controls
and some of the other things I talked
about earlier it really has been
instrumental in creating that
environment that's an extension of our
internal network and the tools that
researchers are comfortable with and
enabling us to really accelerate the use
of the cloud across
once we had that that initial use case
proven art a lot of other business units
within the firm are really now
interested in how they can adopt these
services using this private connectivity
so that was a big thing for us
finally I'm conditions again this is a
very important element in our overall
security posture we believe very
strongly in defense in depth and layered
defenses and I am conditions really
allow us to complement the very
coarse-grained access control that
something like VPC service controls
gives us with a very very fine-grained
and super granular set of conditions
where we can meld those together so
right now I can talk in too much depth
about i''m conditions because there's a
there's a talk on it tomorrow and some
of the features are going to bethe
tomorrow but if you do want some depth
again please reach out to the product
team Chris Lowe the product manager is
fantastic what I can say is that I am
conditions allows us to not take some of
the principles that VPC service controls
give us for things like controlling
where we want to allow access to API is
from and actually embed those into I am
in some cases where VPC service controls
may not be the right solution or in
cases where we wanted as an additional
layer of depth in our defense in depth
stack so really powerful again and
really helpful in terms of google
listening to our concerns and really
building solutions that enable these and
allowing us to adopt these early and
test them and help with the iteration
like those things are super valuable
so again over the years it it's almost
been hammered into security people that
no matter how much you focus on
prevention and trying to keep bad things
from happening there's an adage that if
you think you're not compromised you've
probably been compromised for a while
and just don't realize it
yeah in terms of complementing that
security posture it's important to also
have detection and response controls and
cloud security command center again is a
very cloud native product from Google
that allows us to have a single console
in a single interface with which we can
monitor the security posture of our
Google cloud again we were very early
adopters we work very tightly with Andy
and his team about CSEC
we hope that evolve one of my colleagues
is speaking on how we actually use CSEC
in terms of monitoring our security
posture for the cloud but again this is
a lot of the security teams that start
to move towards the cloud you see this
kind of mindset of we want to replicate
the security stack in the security
controls we have on-premise in the cloud
and that's really the wrong way to think
about it
all right the problems are fundamentally
different if you think about and anybody
here who's a user of the cloud you know
that the scale of the cloud in the pace
of adoption is huge compared to what you
have on premise and again you'd be
creating tech that you'd be creating
suboptimal solutions by trying to bring
everything back in-house and put it in
the same console and sure there is some
value there in having a single pane of
glass but really if you're thinking
cloud natively you want to use
cloud-based solutions to deal with the
cloud and cloud security command center
is a very strong evolving technology in
that space which which we're really
excited about as a cousin to CSC C is
the open source project for SETI that
that Google sponsors for SETI is really
well used and contributed to by
companies like Spotify we contribute to
it from an open-source perspective it
really is a powerful tool for us because
historically we had a model where when
we were making changes in the Google
cloud we'd go through a very strong
upfront review process you would review
the code would review the implementation
we'd go to deployment and then things
would be deployed right and who audits
that infrastructure sure we could audit
it but we have multiple projects
auditing it manually is less than ideal
so this really didn't scale for us what
what we wanted is again thinking in a
cloud native approach we wanted a
perspective where we could automate our
security posture we wanted to have a
place where we could aggregate our our
inventory at any given point in time and
then apply security policy to that and
validate that our assumptions are still
upheld just in an automated fashion so
we deployed for city for city was really
helpful for us from that perspective and
actually a lot of the work that we've
done is integrating for cities so that
when for city fires an alert it'll
actually be viewable in cloud security
command
I mean again we're using the cloud to
secure the cloud and you'll notice I
didn't talk at all about stackdriver but
logs and monitoring I think those are
just a given we're just talking about
the next level of monitoring in the
cloud not not the fundamentals so we've
talked about a lot of technologies and a
lot of tools that helped us get to a
decent security posture but it's also
important to talk about process and I
have a story that jack wall will really
resonate with jack and with one of my
colleagues chris in the audience the way
that we did deployments in the cloud
historically also evolved over time you
know back in the early days we had a
couple people who had or government
privileges and those were the people who
you went to if he needed changes made
and that was okay and it helped us
iterate really quickly but again
thinking about our fundamental security
principles that put us in a position
where if that person were compromised by
an attacker the keys to the kingdom were
right there I think we'd do whatever
they wanted
so that was less than ideal so we took a
step back and we thought about how we
could try to mitigate that threat and we
came up with v2 and v2 was that nobody
had woke admin privileges anymore we
created one user principle who was our
super org ID Minh and that user was used
for break glass changes and in terms of
our security posture you know changes
that required anything to do with
storage or identity and access
management or networking configurations
anything that could open up systems or
data we consider those to be break glass
changes so what we did was we'd have a
workflow where when somebody needed one
of these changes they'd submit the
change request to us the security team
would review the change and approve it
and then what we'd have to do is we have
to pair up with someone in the public
cloud engineering team because they had
the password to the super user account
and we had the corresponding security
key and then you had separation of
duties and you could make the change and
that was fantastic for us from a
security perspective but from an agility
perspective it wasn't great right there
were so many manual steps ultimately it
culminated in you having two resources
who all really busy and somebody was
just sitting around watching somebody
else type things
or click around which was really
suboptimal so again we took a step back
and thought about how we could use cloud
native technologies and our own
processes to enable these workflows and
what we needed a tad was doing a project
together with Jack again where we built
the solution for automated deployment we
built this in in a manner that now when
somebody wants one of those changes
they'll merge Google cloud deployment
manager template code to a source
control repo we'll review it and approve
it and merge it and that kicks off an
event-driven C ICD pipeline that will
then have an artifact ready to be
deployed on the other side of that
because the security team doesn't know
when the optimal deployment time is for
an engineering team it doesn't
automatically deploy it's just ready to
deploy and we have a UI that's protected
by identity aware proxy that then allows
a user to log in and then hit a button
to deploy the deployment they can
rollback they can do all sorts of things
again Google enabled us to do this with
the technologies like IIP like cloud
functions like app engine flex really
really powerful tooling and thinking
about things in a cloud native way
finally I won't happen there's too much
but least privilege is really critical
to us as a core tenet and again Jack had
spoken about where we started out with
just the owner editor viewer today we
don't use anything but custom iam roles
so anytime somebody needs to perform a
workflow or we have a new team that's
onboarding to the cloud we we spend time
to understand what each specific role
within that business needs to do their
job and we craft and iam role with
exactly the permissions that are
required for that and give it to that
team that allows us to also share those
roles across multiple teams again I
talked about templates and source
control that's really powerful for us
and in the event that that user were
compromised we absolutely know what the
impact of that compromise is based on
what their privileges are so again
custom item roles went to beta a while
back a really powerful tool for us even
over and above the curated roles at
Google now publishers so we talked a lot
about very specific controls things that
we had to address our problem
obviously we only had 15 50 minutes so
they were a lot that we couldn't get
into but some of the quick takeaways in
terms of lessons learned from our
journey and our process as if I haven't
said it enough in this talk it's really
important to collaborate with Google you
know we work very tightly with our
accounting our business manager Tamm
customer engineer are fantastic but we
also work really closely with product
managers and with engineers and again I
can't tell you how empowering it is to
be working on a product and actually be
on the phone way and hang out with the
engineers that are building that product
that that sort of level of iteration
really is what enables quick like
velocity acceleration in the cloud that
that partnership is fundamentals and
again like Google also needs to
understand what your problems are in
order to resolve them and we've actually
seen value not only for our own firm in
some of the controls that I talked about
that evolved through some of our issues
but also everybody else gets to benefit
from them so in the same way as it's
important to contribute to open source
it's important to work with vendors and
help them understand what the problems
are in order to resolve those sandboxing
is interesting again thinking about
velocity it's it's really easy in an
organization like ours with the security
posture that's really tight - just
stifle workflows by not allowing people
to do things but again that's not very
cloud native like how do you enable
people to iterate and experiment with
the freedom that they need but also
maintain your security posture
the answer is difficult right so the
approach that we took is segmenting out
development entirely so we have a
separate G suite domain and a separate
Google cloud platform organization link
to that that's just not accessible from
within two Sigma like you have to be on
our guest network or on an unmanaged
device to access that environment and
what that gives us is the ability to
allow people the freedoms to have the
privileges that they need to iterate and
develop and also protect our IP because
you can't get to our IP from there so
that ultimately led to even better work
for us for us because then when we have
a new team or a team that's considering
a new project
they already really understand what it
is they need from the cloud platform and
I am
and could just tell us that and we could
easily review that approve it and roll
it out again I talked a lot about being
cloud native again there are obvious
security trade-offs here right if you
want the ultimate set of control you'd
build everything on top of Google cloud
engine VMs and then you maintain pretty
much as much as you want but there's a
trade-off there right then you have to
worry about administration you have to
worry about patching you have to worry
about vulnerability management the
trade-off there is to use completely
managed services something like data
prop where you don't have to worry about
any of those things but in turn you lose
that level of transparency in the stack
and you know it's difficult there's no
right or wrong answer every use cases
business risk dependent data dependent
but the key thing as a security team is
to understand what those trade-offs are
and present them to the business so that
the business can make the appropriate
decision based on the value of the
project and the value of the data so
again cloud native controls really are
pushes wherever we can use something
that Google's built they'll support it
develop it and maintain it better than
any custom hacks that we'd have to put
in so that's how preference layer
defenses again I spoke about defense in
depth
extensively so I won't spend too much
time but you don't want to be in a
position where a single compromise or a
mistake or even a failure on the cloud
providers side would lead to you having
a really bad day if your one mistake or
one compromise away from being on the
front page of the newspaper that's a bad
place to be so the more that you can
layer defenses even if it takes more
work even if it's unnecessary I
I like insurance we have an insurance
business or I am in that space and the
last take away from us is is it's
important to move fast again a lot of
organizations that are very security
sensitive have a tendency to take a lot
of time in review and and rightly so the
analysis and getting in-depth but again
you're blocking the business's velocity
and people are going to find ways to
work around you if you take six months
to review one new service so find
workflows and again to borrow quote from
somebody else
Jason Chen who's an engineering director
at Netflix
he said Security's job
should be to build guardrails not gates
so ultimately we're not there yet but my
team's goal is to enable none of our
developers have to think about security
at all we could just build a platform we
can work with our partners Google to
build a platform where developers can
just do their jobs without ever having
to think about security so on that I'd
like to hand back over to offer it to to
wrap up with some final thoughts and
final notes so I hope you got from that
sort of a couple thoughts one is we were
pretty early adopter in this and you you
heard about what we did in that stage
from Jacques and his presentation um
when I got to 2 Sigma just about three
years ago we effectively didn't use the
cloud for much of anything I don't know
maybe a couple of tiny things and we
were fairly able because of jacque's and
a few others work to get to a situation
where maybe half of our compute load was
sort of on the cloud although we did it
in ways that were not as cloud native as
we would like and we were not able to
fully use all the services that we knew
that were coming as we got to the second
phase of this working more closely with
Google we were able to use standard
technologies after certainly providing
input as to what they should be but able
to use those and now we've gotten to
that stage where not only are we doing a
lot of compute in the cloud we're doing
a lot more heterogeneous computing in
the cloud using a lot more different
services and we do think that's the
future of all this is that I don't think
any of us unless maybe we're Google or a
very very large company can build all
the things that that that we will want
to use they're just too big
we can't can't build bigquery or
something like that it's a huge project
to go do so we're very excited about the
future we think that Google now
understands a lot of these principles of
that really come from the notion that
ensuring that data is not universally
accessible and useful that's not the
only thing right you need to be able to
control that access and you need to be
able to
roll it in a way as Nick said very
eloquently that you're not one mistake
or one attack away from being on the
front page of the New York Times as it
has been said so we certainly don't we
we think that seems to now be the case
and we're very excited about being able
to rapidly move forward in a lot more
fronts these are the talks that we're
giving so on the security I guess it's
already kind of late on Tuesday so
without a time machine you can't go back
to the earlier talks that we do not have
if we did that would be quite
interesting in our business and in on
Wednesday and Thursday you'll see the
talks though that are listed in
insecurity and as I mentioned the
serverless computing talk the halite
talk I think is at the same time slot
right it's also at 4:30 5:00 in the
afternoon if you want to have some fun
and see how maybe IAI will continue to
be explored in ways that are really
challenging so we should open this up to
some questions after the obligatory
we're hiring we do exciting things as
you can tell we're trying to be on the
forefront more than any other firm that
we know if we get to answer the question
with all of the security and computation
what is the effect of machine learning
on AI in the entire world of economic
optimization no one knows the answer to
that question in my opinion I've been in
this field leading research teams for
many decades we know small areas where
it's useful we don't know the breadth so
the firm is dedicated to some really
interesting problems that have solved
will make economies in the world I think
far more efficient and make our firm
very successful so thank you very much
for your time let's take some questions
if there are some
[Music]